hey what's up guys my name is a turn-on
welcome back to my OpenGL series so last
time we talked about mass and we started
getting into maths and all the math like
topics that will come in the future in
this in this OpenGL series and in your
graphics programming journey today and
we're going to be specifically focusing
on one small part of that which is
projection projection is one of the
biggest actual things that we need to
solve when it comes to rendering
graphics on the screen is part of the
transformation pipeline which we will
continue to explore over the coming
weeks but today I just want to focus on
projection and this is not gonna be a
super long episode because I don't want
to over complicate this for you and have
you scratching your head we're not going
to talk too much about the technical
details and how the maths works because
that is completely relevant for 99% of
cases I know they're probably bunch of
you interested in how it actually works
so that you can kind of write your own
version of OpenGL from scratch or
something well we might cover that in
the future but today practically
speaking what is projection in OpenGL
how does it work and why do we use it so
to put it simply projection is just how
we go from having some kind of arbitrary
coordinate system in our 3d world or 2d
world doesn't matter I mean 2d worlds
are really 3d anyway as far and looking
gel is concerned it's how we go from
having coordinates or vertex positions
in that space to being able to somehow
map them to our window where we're
actually rendering on our computer
screen so we have to project them
somehow onto this 2d surface you might
have this massive 3d world with Hills
and terrain and characters and all of
that which in the end obviously just
balls down to a bunch of triangles which
are made up of vertex positions but in
the end that 3d world has to somehow be
rendered onto our 2d monitor and into
our window that is what projection is it
is essentially the maths that converts
all of those 3d points in space into
something that is in a 2d kind of window
that is what projection is so forget
everything you know about projection or
whatever that's all it is it is as
simple as that
now what do I mean by convert into
positions what does that even mean the
actual transformation that happens with
a projection matrix which we kind of
talked about last time in math we
we will touch on today as well is we
just convert all of those positions that
we have into something called normalized
device coordinates which is basically
some kind of normalized space that we
can then map to our window now a
normalized space means that literally a
coordinate system between negative 1 and
1 in every access XY and Z right so what
I'm saying is the picture that you have
a window does not matter evolution does
not matter at this rate doesn't matter
what size your window is all that we
know is that the left side of our window
let's just say we render in full-screen
so the left side will be negative 1 the
right side will be positive 1 the bottom
will be negative 1 and the top will be
positive 1 let's not worry too much
about Z at this point because that's not
as important to visualize as x and y so
that's it we have our computer monitor
we have our window open where we're
actually rendering all of our graphics
and that is between negative 1 and 1
that is how we that that is the space
that we need to have all of our bird
expositions in so that we can actually
start rasterizing stuff onto the screen
however what we have is like this 3d
world or maybe this 2d object somewhere
on our screen and we need to convert it
into that space that's what a projection
matrix does and in fact up until really
last episode we've just we have not been
using a projection matrix which is why
you probably heard me say that our space
is between negative 1 and 1 and in other
words when we actually made that churner
logo in the textures video as an example
we plotted that geometry like the vertex
positions that we actually use there had
to be between a negative 1 and 1 and I
think I wrote something like negative
zero point 5 to positive 0.5 or
something like that because without a
projection matrix we have nothing to can
we don't have an actual matrix to
convert our vertex positions into that
normalized device coordinates space so
we have to provide it initially because
if we don't if we're gonna be well
outside of that that coordinate space
then we're not going to see anything on
the screen because as far as the Spirit
is concerned as far as what actually
gets rendered on to our window that has
to be between negative 1 and 1 it has to
be but
it's a bit difficult for us to deal with
something that's just constantly
negative one to one
I mean as an example let's just say
we're entering a square but our window
is not square is 4 by 3 or it's 16 by 9
we can't just I mean we could
theoretically do all the maps every time
we calculate vertex positions and I just
keep doing the maths every time so that
we do get a square but wouldn't it be
easier to just kind of be able to say
okay well how about the left side of our
screen
maybe is 0 the right side of our screen
is width so maybe my my window is 1280
by 720 so let's just say that the left
side is 0 right side is 1280 now I can
render anywhere in between there and
then we'll worry about the maths of
actually converting that into negative 1
to 1
later so that is essentially what a
projection can do for you it lets you
decide what your coordinate space is so
that you can render objects however you
like whether they be inside the space
maybe they are outside of the screen
because we're dealing with some kind of
camera system that only shows the same
partially that's a projection let's
let's do all that and for 3d it's
especially important because if you
think about what a 3d scene looks like
it's not just as simple as kind of
converting your projection from negative
1 to 1 and like wall scaling it rather
from a value from a large kind of value
into negative 1 to 1 so as that example
that I just gave from 0 to 1280 is my
kind of projection matrix I'm scaling
that down into something that is
negative 1 to 1
that's might seem to you like oh that's
easy you know just divide this by like
1280 and like multiply but 2 or whatever
subtract 1 you know easy right done but
if you think about it perspective
projection which is what is typically
used in a 3d world if you just take a
photo of something and you take a look
at objects objects that are further away
actually become smaller they'd be
smaller than the photograph right and
you don't even have to take a photo if
it is you look with your own eyes and
you can see hard that you know I can bet
you know Mountain over there is really
is this big from here because of the way
that perspective works because objects
that are further away tend to look
smaller that is also a an actual
projection
needs to be applied if you're dealing
with a 3d scene and that's what a
projection matrix can do it will
essentially look at the Z value and say
okay well objects with the larger Z
value if you use a coordinate system
whereas positive Z is like far those
objects are those vertices with a lower
with a higher Z value will actually end
up being closer to the middle of the
camera which essentially will just make
them smaller so that's really important
as well and when we get into 3d stuff
you'll see how important a perspective
projection is but anyway if we just take
a look at this little PowerPoint slide
that I prepared here we have two
different main types of projection here
we have orthographic projection and
perspective projection so orthographic
projection is usually used for 2d
rendering now when I say usually keep in
mind first of all while orthographic is
usually used for 2d it's not always used
for 2d it's totally fine to use
orthographic it's for 3d that's actually
done quite commonly because it presents
a slightly different view that might be
useful to something like a level editor
or a 3d modeling program perspective is
usually used for 3d but I mean
everything is 3d anyway because there is
the concept of Z so if you're thinking
of a 2d platformer that might actually
be using a perspective projection
because there might be elements further
away if you look at a game such as
Rayman like the new Rayman games they
have that concept of depth even though
you can really only move on what is
mostly kind of a 2d plane a 2d axis so
don't take these as like okay respective
3d lots of opportunity not true it can
be used in both cases but usually when
we think of an orthographic projection
we think of rendering something like UI
or something maybe a 2d game or
something like that whereas when we
think that when we think of perspective
we think of like a first-person shooter
or something like that what we actually
have a 3d world that we're rendering but
that's not necessarily all they're used
for anyway while we say we here with
this orthographic projection is that
objects that are further away are not
actually they don't get smaller like
they do with perspective you can see
these cubes they look like they're
further away because they're small
and our eyes are used to that because
that's how we see in the real world
whereas these two cubes here they're the
same distance I mean for all intents and
purposes what you see in these two
diagrams that I just literally made in
five seconds in PowerPoint using the
shapes thing anyway they're awful I know
these things that are further away let
they have the same vertex positions as
these ones here it's just that these are
using orthographic projection and these
are using perspective projection because
you know these cubes do have the same
width the same height the same depth all
of that right they just happen to be at
a further Z value and the perspective
projection maps that actually goes on
when we multiply these vertices with our
projection matrix that is what makes
them smaller because they have a high Z
value but at the end of the day every
single vertex position of all of these
cubes gets mapped into a space that is
between negative 1 and 1 and that's what
the normalized device coordinates are
they're a space that are between kind of
negative 1 and 1 anything that is
outside of that so for example if I have
a vertex that ends up being calculated
to be negative 2 that does not get
rendered it gets cold because it's
outside of our actual view it's outside
of our frosting now we're definitely
going to talk more about you know these
projections as we start to use them but
let's take a look at them in our card
base if I go back to my opengl code over
here I have this projection matrix that
I'm creating so what I'm doing here is
I'm saying I have an orthographic
projection between negative 2 & 2 in X
and negative 1 point 5 and positive 1.5
in Y and then this is just the Z the
neuron far so we're not going to worry
too much about that for now anything
that I render any vertex position these
are my vertex positions any vertex
position that lies outside of this these
bounds will not appear because this is
the leftmost expound this is the
rightmost expound so if I was to adjust
any of these x coordinates to be say
negative 2.5 or positive 5 or positive
100 they're not actually going to render
because that is my view that is all that
I say and
at the end of the day this orthographic
projection when multiplied with these
vertex positions is going to convert
them to be in that negative one to one
space so as an example since we have
chosen negative two to two
that means that zero is in fact the
center the middle of our actual screen
if I have a vertex of negative 0.5 you
can tell that that's kind of from the
middle it's a quarter of the way towards
the leftmost bound because 0.5 is a
quarter of two so since this
orthographic matrix is going to convert
this position to be between negative one
and one then what is a quarter between
zero and negative one is 0.25 so we can
just tell just by eyeballing this
because this this projection matrix is
so simple that this will become 0.25 on
our actual screen and if we do hit f5
it'll be a little bit hard to tell
because I believe we are actually
rendering a texture which is like
partially transparent but yeah I'm just
going to get rid of that if I go to my
shader
I'm just going to make it so that we
output instead of outputting the texture
color we're just gonna output white so
just back for 1 and if we look at this
now you can see that if you kind of
eyeball this you know this is the center
of the screen here and this this
leftmost kind of edge that we have from
our square is a quarter of the way to
the left because it becomes 0.25 where
this or negative 0.25 where this is
negative 1 hopefully this math is kind
of making sense to you I don't really
want to dive in and start drawing
diagrams or anything because it's not
really that useful to know this in
practice you just have to know that what
the projection matrix does is it
converts it into that normalized kind of
device coordinate space of negative 1 to
1 that's really all this happening it's
just a simple maths operation there's
nothing too fancy about projection
matrices if we go over here and what I'm
actually going to do is in my
application I'm going to instead of
drawn into a 640 by 480 I want to
convert this to be 960 by 540 now what
I'm going to do now well let's just hit
f5 and see what happens remember we
still have the same projection
so it still kind of looks the same I
mean it looks stretched out because
we've changed the resolution of our
window but kept the projection mastery
the same it's no longer our square is no
longer a square it's kind of a rectangle
if we go back to our orthographic
projection let's play a little bit
around with this so what I'm going to do
is what I mentioned earlier in my
example which is just changing it to be
basically in pixel space so one to one
pixel mapping so to do that I'm going to
make a zero in my leftmost edge 960 my
rightmost edge because that's the
horizontal resolution I'm then going to
make 0 in my bottom and 540 my top and I
guess I will have to make this a flirt
because this is a bit sad ok cool so
let's hit f5 all right cool so we don't
see anything at all and that would be
because well I mean we do it's just hard
to see because of course if we are in
pixel space then this square is one by
one pixel which is obviously one pixel
which is time so what we can do is just
boost this so I might just set this to
be like ten point five instead of 0.5
I'll just add a one here just to keep it
simple still and if we hit at five you
can now kind of begin to see it but it's
over here in the bottom left because
what we've done of course is we've made
the bottom the like our zero comma zero
coordinate to be the bottom left of our
window so if we scroll back up what I'm
going to do is just rewrite this so I
was just going to modify it but let's
just rewrite it let's make this a
hundred by what will will start at 100
by 100 and then I think we go
anti-clockwise it kinda looks like we
are going clockwise give me a second
yeah okay cool so we'll just say a
hundred by hundred then we go
anti-clockwise to the right so we'll say
200 by still 100 and all this gear to
this point five and then we'll say 200
again 4x and 100 here and then
we'll become 200 200 okay so if we head
up five now with these new coordinates
that we have here we should see a square
somewhere and yes we do and if I go back
to my shader and I change this to be a
to be our actual texture then you can
see if we get this rendering here so
what we've done here as you can see this
really we've just played with the
coordinate system a little bit we've
changed our projection matrix to be
between 0 and 9 64 X 0 and 544 Y so
essentially we've changed
we've changed to be per pixel based on
that on the resolution of our window and
then because of that we've had to adjust
the positions of our geometry to
actually be in that space or rather than
be like negative 0.5 positive 0.5 we've
actually had to change them to be
something a bit bigger like 100 and 200
and all of that because now we've
redefined what space we actually define
out that expositions in but at the end
of the day what happens is these vertex
positions get multiplied with our matrix
and that is what converts them back into
being negative 0.5 by 0.5 let's take a
look at another example so just to make
this absolutely clear we have this 100
by 100 what I'm going to do is I'll keep
my projection matrix but I'll make a GLM
back for I'll call this DP vertex
position and I'll just create a vet for
here that has the coordinate 100 by 100
and then 0 1 okay so we don't have a set
coordinate and for one and for W what
it's going to specify one what I'm going
to do then is type in jail and vet full
result equals proj times VP so I'm
actually doing that multiplication
myself right here on the CPU just to see
what the result is so that we can
actually see now remember what I said
what we're doing here is this projection
matrix is supposed to take our
coordinate our vertex position and
convert it into a space that is between
negative 1 and 1 so if I hit f5 and I
take a look at this if we look at our
actual projection matrix it looks a bit
wild I mean it's like 0.02 whatever what
I really need to look at that our vertex
position is of course 100 100
zero and one if I could have ten here to
do this calculation take a look at our
result now it might be a little bit hard
to see I'll really tell if it's worked a
month but you can see that at the X&Y is
that of course was always 0 w 0 man 1
but x and y have changed from being a
hundred 100 to negative zero point seven
nine and negative zero point six two if
we go to so remember those two values
zero point negative zero point seven
nine and negative zero point six two if
we look at this and we take a look at
the bottom left most coordinate that
kind of makes sense doesn't it like this
if we were to change our mapping to not
use a projection matrix anymore and we
had negative one to one you can kind of
imagine this as being around seventy
percent of the way to there from the
middle right so what it's done clearly
is it has converted our 100 by 100 to be
in that negative one to one space and
that is what projection does in both 2d
and 3d so in other words orthographic or
perspective again nothing to do with to
your 3d it's just what people commonly
associated with so in perspective and
orthographic projection doesn't matter
the same thing happens all you're doing
is you're telling your computer how to
convert from whatever space you're
currently dealing it with which is
something that you define yourself to
that negative one to one normalized
device coordinates space and that is all
there is to projection in OpenGL anyway
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did you can hit the like button you
can also help support the series by
going over to patreon icon force at the
channel let me know what you think of
these kind of more technical videos on
one hand I really like making them
because I think that like people like me
probably would be interested to I wish
like someone explained it as simple as I
hope waited here today when I was
learning this kind of stuff but on the
other hand I know that some of you
probably want to see more things on the
screen and one see more progress I want
to get to the fun stuff so let me know
what your thoughts are on this if you're
ok with this if you want me to do more
practical things and maybe come back and
do the theory later but either way
you're not supposed to is we're gonna
badger Anakin for such the churner huge
thank you to all the patrons who make
these videos possible we're not
here without you guys so thank you so
much I will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]